[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه صور المباشره من اسطنبول
وترقب للمؤتمر الصحفي بين الرئيسين التركي
والاوكراني للحديث عن مخرجات زياره
زيلينسكي الى تركيا من نيويورك تريدنا هذه
الصور حيث تنعقد الان جلسه مغلقه لمجلس
الامن لبحث العمليه الاسرائيليه في مخيم
جنين قبل ايام
ومن واشنطن مؤتمر صحفي للرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وحديث بشان خفض التكاليف عن
الامريكيين ويتوقع ان يتطرق الرئيس
الامريكي الى ملفات متعدده داخليه وخارجيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في مساعدات تفتح باب الجدل
البنتاجون يؤكد امداد اوكرانيا بذخيره
عنقوديه لاول مره معارضه المانيه للخطوه
وتحذير روسي من خطوره تزويد بوسائل تدمير
حديثه وقبيل انعقاد قمه
في الدول الاعضاء بزياره لتركيا تحسم
القول بان كيان لم تستوفي شروط الانضمام
للنيتو
وضمن مسلسل تصعيد مستمر في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تقتل فلسطينيين اثنين في
اقتحاما البلده القديمه في نابلس وثالثا
شماليه رام الله
مواجهات مع المستوطنين في الخليل تسفر عن
اصابه فلسطيني ومجلس الامن يعقد جلسه
مغلقه بشان العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في جنين
الجيش السوداني يقول انه قصف مواقع في
محيط القياده والاذاعه والتلفزيون والدعم
السريع يعلن صده هجوما استهدف مقر قيادتها
العامه مصدر بالخارجيه السودانيه يؤكد
للجزيره اعتذار البرهان عن لقاء مع حماتي
في اجتماع لايجاد بادي سببا
وتحذير اممي من امتداد المعارك وخطوره
الوضع في دارفور
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا استمرار استجال بين تويتر
ومتى بعد اطلاق منصه سريدز المنصه التي
يتوقع كثيرون ان تنافس تويتر في مكانتها
شركه متى هددت بمقاضات شركه متى في ظل
مقاله انها شكوك بشان امكانيه وصول موظفين
سابقين في تويتر الى اسرار تجاريه
ومعلومات سريه لاستطاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
هل ستهدد منصه الجديده وجود وحضور منصه
تويتر جاءت نتائج تصويتكم كالتالي
39% يرون وجود خطوره من فريدز على تويتر
41% لا يعتقدون ان هناك خطرا على منصه
تويتر فيما صوت 20% لصالح خيار امكانيه
تاثير على تويتر بشكل جزئي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلال اهل قضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
اذا مع ترقب المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان والاوكراني في اسطنبول
يستمر الحديث عما ستسفر عنه جوله زيلينسكي
سباقا لقمه النيتو في محاوله لحشد الدعم
لكياف واشنطن خرجت اليوم بتصريح يقطع
الطريق امام السعي الاوكراني للانضمام
القريب لحلف الاطلسي وقالت ان كياف لم
تستوفي شروط الانضمام وان الطرح الامر
خلال قمه ليتوانيا غير وارد
من اجل اشاره واضحه للانضمام الى النيتو
واشياء اخرى يصل ويجول في اكثر من مدينه
وعاصمه اوروبيه في ايام قليله اسطنبول هي
اخر محطه في جوله الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
يريد من نظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
امورا وعليه ايضا الانصات لمقترحات
التركيه التي تلعب دور الوسيط في الحرب
الطاحنه هو ضيف في الدوله الراعيه لاتفاق
الحبوب عشيه مرور 500 يوم على الحرب لا
شيء متروك للصدفه اكدت ان قرا ان
المحادثات بين الرئيسين تركز على اتفاق
الحبوب والاسرى وافقي مفاوضات السلام
لانهاء الصراع المسلح عن كثب تبعت روسيا
هذه الزياره التي لا تفسد الوده بينها
وبين تركيا كما اوضح المتحدث باسم
الكرملين
ان التسويه السياسيه والدبلوماسيه في
اوكرانيا غير حاليا بسبب عدم رغبه كييف
وواشنطن في ذلك مشيرا الى ان موسكو لم
تغلق الباب امام عمليه التفاوض ولكنها لا
ترى اي افق لها حتى الان عن افق واضح
ومحدد لعضويتك يا فحلف شمال الاطلسي يبحث
الثلاثاء المقبل في العاصمه الليتوانيه
بزيارته لبعض الدول الاعضاء القريبه منه
جغرافيا لحشد الدعم وتكرار رسائله
المسموعه من قبل والموجهه للمترددين في
قبول عضويه بلاده
قال ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى اكثر من مجرد
التصريح قبل عشر سنوات بان باب الحلفى
مفتوح امامها وفي سلوفاكيا طالب بموقف
موحد
اعتقد انه لا توجد وحده موقف كافيه بشان
مساله انضمامنا وهذا يشكل تهديدا لقوه
الحلف نتوقع وحده صف الحلف لان قوته في
وحدته
تصريحات الامين العام للنيتو المهادنه لا
تعكس حقيقه الانقسامات فبرلين وواشن لا
تريدان الاستعجال في وضع جدول زمني لدخول
اوكرانيا الحلف لان ذلك يعني الدخول في
حرب مباشره مع روسيا يفضل تفاديها
سيؤكدون مجددا ان اوكرانيا ستصبح عضوا
بالحلف
وسيتحدون بشان طريقه تقريب اوكرانيا من
هدفها لم يوضح الصيغه التي سيتفق عليها او
ربما لم تحدد بعد ولا تحظى بالاجماع من
بلغاريا الى التشيك وسلوفاكي انتهاء
بالتركيا سمعت نفس الجمل من الرئيس
زيلينسكي وهي ضمانات امنيه ومساعدات
عسكريه جديده منها بعيده المدى وجدول زمني
للالتحاق بالنيتو سيرددها ايضا في قمه
فيلينوس هذا الاسبوع فهل من فعل غير
الاجابه الدبلوماسيه المسحوبه بوعود
حسابات السياسه المعقده والبعيده المدى
تجعل من الصعب ان تكون كل طلباته مستجابه
الحرب طالت اكثر من اللازم وثمنها يثقل
كاهل الجميع
وكما ذكرنا يفترض في اي لحظه ان يخرج
المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك بين الرئيسين
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وبلودي من اسطنبول
وهذا هي القاعه حيث يفترض ان يتم هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي ولكن بالانتظار معنى من
اسطنبول الكاتب والمحلل السياسي بيرجان
توتار سيد بيرجان ما عناوين ابرز عناوين
هذه الزياره
في اسطنبول هناك يمكننا ما نسميه زياره
تاريخيه بالنسبه الى
زياره السيد زيلينسكي وفي اسطنبول اللقاء
الان بين الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس
يستمر وهناك عمل على المسائل والمسائل
معروفه المسائل المطروحه المعروفه كما
اشرتم في التقرير ان دخول اوكرانيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي والى حلف شمال الاطلسي
بالنسبه الى اوكرانيا هذه هي المساله
الاساسيه بالنسبه الى تركيا اتفاقيه
الحبوب تصدير الحبوب التي سوف ينتهي العمل
بها في السابع من يوليو وتود روسيا ان
تمدد المهله بالنسبه الى تركيا ايضا
المساله الاساسيه هي امن البحر الاسود
ومساله الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا والجهود
الايه الى وقف هذا النزاع
والعلاقه ايضا مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ومع الاتحاد الاوروبي ولا تؤثر
على العلاقه بين تركيا وروسيا وهذا يمكن
ان يكون من تبعات هذه الحرب ان تتاثر هذه
العلاقه وتركيا تنظر بطريقه واضحه ايذاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا تود تركيا ان تصل هذه
الحرب الى نهايتها
لمصلحه الشعبين الروسي والاوكراني ولمصلحه
شعوب العالم
وان تركيا
سنفصل بكل ببعض هذه النقاط المهمه التي
ذكرتها وبعض هذه العناوين ولكن دعنا نشرك
في هذا النقاش من امتياز السيد اوليكسيه
هاران استاذ سياسه المقارنه في جامعه كييف
ومن موسكو السيد ديمتري بابتش المحلل
السياسي مرحبا بكما سيد اوليكس ما الذي
يسعى اليه زيلينسكي في هذه الزياره الى
تركيا
اولا اود القول بان انه قبل ساعه وواحد
كان هناك
انذار
من ضربات جويه في كل اوكرانيا وهذه طريقه
حياتنا وايضا نمدنا في غرب اوكرانيا تتعرض
للقصف فيها مناطق تاريخيه اثريه تتعرض
القصف من قبل روسيين الروس الذين يتصرفون
كعمج ما نريده نحن بالتاكيد هو اننا نريد
ايقاف الحرب
وان تنسحب القوات الروسيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وهنا استطيع القول ان الموقف
التركي واضح
فالتركيا تؤيد السياده راضيه اوكرانيا هذا
امر في غايه الاهميه خاصه نظرا
للتقارب التاريخ بين
تركيا
وبلادي وبالت الي نحن نقدر هذا الدعم
المجموعه المشاكل
يسعى الى ايقاف الحرب وهناك حديث متزايد
عن مساء في هذا الاطار من جهات متعدده
يعني اشرح لنا قليلا
النقله التي حدثت في هذه المساعي
اشرح لنا قليلا ان نقله التي حدثت في هذه
المساعي التي دفعت الى الحديث بشكل متزايد
عن مساعن لانهاء الحرب الاوكراني واضح نحن
نريد تحرير اراضينا هذا والشرطنا الوحيد
على روسيا ان تترك كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
التي يعترف بها العالم كله والان نرى ان
بوتين النظام بوتين قد ضعف وان شاهدنا ذلك
شاهدنا ذلك على الجبهات القتال وايضا داخل
روسيا فهناك هذا التمرد تمرد فاغنار يبين
ان هناك شقاق النظام
لكنه مازال قويا بما يكفي لاستمرار في سفك
الدماء وبالتالي ما نتوقعه
من الخطط السلميه المختلفه المقترحه ان
نتوقع ان الشرط الرئيسي يكون سحب القوات
الروسيه من الاراضي اوكرانيا ولكن رغم ذلك
هناك ايضا بعض الاهداف المحدده التي يمكن
حلها يمكن تحقيقها فورا مثلا اولا استمرار
ممرات نقل القمح والذي روسيا تعيق هذا
الاتفاق وهذا يؤدي المجاعه في كثير من
الدول العالم اذا هذه مشكله يمكن حلها
بسهوله فقط استمرار في هذا الاتفاق هو
الزياره في ظل العناوين المطروحه لسيما
موضوع اتفاق تجديد اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
موضوع انضمام اوكرانيا الى الناتو وحديث
متزايد عن زياره تركيه ربما قد تعقب زياره
زيلينسكي الى تركيا
تؤيد تماما اجراء المفاوضات فاذا تشارك
السيد دردرمان في بعض الدبلوماسيه
المكلوكيه بين كيف موسكو في ذلك جيد وان
السيد بوتين سيسعده ان يلتقي به واننا
منفتحون امام اي اقتراحات تقدم في هذا
الصدد وعود اتذكر في السنه الماضيه تقريبا
السنه في اسطنبول فقد كان لك حل وسط شامله
حياديه اوكرانيا وهو الشيء الرئيسي اللي
تطلبه تطلبه روسيا عدم عضيتها في النيتو
وايضا حياد
اوكرانيا فيها قواعد رسميه وغير رسميه
للنيتو على اراضي اوكرانيا اما فيما يتعلق
بصفقه الحبوب القمح لا اعتقد ان روسيا
ستمدد هذا الاتفاق لانه كانت هناك مؤشرات
صادره من الحكومه الروسيه بان هذا الاتفاق
الحبوبي
استخدامه فالقمح لا يصل للدول فقيره في
افريقيا ولشرق الاوسط يرسل الى اوروبا وقد
شاهدنا ذلك في بولندا حيث مؤخرا حيث ان
الحكومه منعت اي اي استيرادات من القمح من
من اوكرانيا لان الاسواق الاخرى البولانيه
غرقت القمح الاوكراني وبالتالي صفقه كانت
لارسال هذا هذا القمح الى الدول الفقيره
وهذا امر كرره السيد بوتين عده مرات
وبالتالي لست متاكدا ان روسيا ستمدد هذا
الاتفاق بعد السابع عشر من يوليو تموز
عندما يصل الى نهايته اما فيما يتعلق
بالوضع على جبهه القتال فان ان روسيا
تواجه الهجوم الاوكراني هو ذكركم بين
اوكرانيا تحدث عن السيطره على 100 ميل
مربع من الاراضي
وهذه مجرد شيء بسيط جدا ليس بالشيء الخطير
حقا ولكن كانت هناك اخبار سيئه اليوم بانه
الولايات المتحده ستبعث
بعقائد الذخائر عنقوديه الى اوكرانيا وهذه
الذخائر طبعا نذكركم تمنعها عده معاهدات
120 دوله في العالم وافقت اتوقعت اتفاقا
باستخدام هذه الذخائر العنقوديه هذا
الموضوع سيد سيد
السيد الديمتري بابتش ولكن دعني اعود الى
السيد بيرجنتو تار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
من اسطنبول سيد برجان اريد ان اسالك في
نقطتين الاولى امكانيه عدم تجديد موسكو
التزامها باتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب كيف يمكن
ان تتعامل انقره مع هكذا امر
رئيس هيئه
روسيا لديها بعض المشكلات وعبرت عن بعض
الانتقادات المرتبطه
باتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب بحيث لم تمكن هذه
الاتفاقيه روسيا من تصدير حبوبها لانه لم
يتم الامتثال لهذه الاتفاقية وهذا ما منع
روسيا من تصدير الحبوب لذلك هناك
بعض التردد بالنسبه الى تجديد
موسكو لهذا الاتفاق ولكن في النهايه اعتقد
ان روسيا لا يمكنها ان تغلق القنوات
الدبلوماسيه سواء كان ذلك بالنسبه الى
اتفاقيه الحبوب او بالنسبه الى المسائل
الاخرى المرتبطه بالاقتصاد الروسي
بالمجالات المرتبط
بعد المرتبط بالطاقه اذا روسيا في موضوع
الناتو سيد بيرجان توتار ماذا سيكون عليه
موقف تركيا من
المساله المطروحه حاليا وهي انضمام
اوكرانيا الى حلف الشمال الاطلسي
[موسيقى]
موقف تركيا واضح بالنسبه الى هذا الموضوع
تود
اوكرانيا او تود تركيا بالنسبه الى عضويه
اوكرانيا في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي خلف
شمال الاطلسي الافضل ولكن حقيقه الامر او
الواقع هو ان ذلك مستحيل بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا ان تصبح دوله عضو في حلف شمال
الاطلسين هناك مشاكل حاليا
روسيا وهي دوله جاره لاوكرانيا وهذا لا
يسمح لاوكرانيا بالانضمام الى النيتو لان
من شان ذلك ان يفاقم المشكله هذا في
الظروف المتعلقه باوكرانيا ولكن انا اسالك
عن الموقف التركي من هذا الامر لانه كانت
هناك
جولهنسكي على بعض الدول
والحديث كله عن دعم هذا المسع اريد ان
افهم ما هو الموقف التركي
سبورت
يعني
[موسيقى]
تدعم عمليه التوسع حلف شمال الاطلسي
بالنسبه الى كوسوفو
والدول الاخرى في البلقان او بقدونيا كذلك
اذا الموقف التركي يدعم عمليه توسيع حلف
شمال الاطلسي
ولكن بالنسبه الى تركيا
[موسيقى]
من اجل ان
تدعم
عضويه عضويه اوكرانيا في حلف شمال
الاطلسيه يجب ان تحل المشكله مع روسيا
وهي نقطه مطروحه على اجنده النقاش
موقف تركيا مبدئيا هو بدعم عضويه اوكرانيا
في حلف شمال الاطلسي ولكن تقول تركيا ان
ذلك لن يحل المشكله بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
من جهه او الاتحاد الاوروبي وروسيا من جهه
اخرى من اجل حل هذه المشكلات نحن بحاجه
الى بعد جديد شكرا لك الكاتب المحلل
السياسي بيرجان توتار من اسطنبول وشكرا
لضيفنا اوليكسيه هارون في جامعه كييف من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه
والمحلل السياسي ديمتري بابتش ضيفنا من
موسكو
اعلن البنتاجون رسميا تزويد اوكرانيا
بقذائف عنقوديه وقال المتحدث باسم
البنتاجون ان اوكرانيا تعهدت بتقديم
ضمانات بعدم الحاق الضرر بالمدنيين بعد
تزويدها بالذخائر العنقوديه كما قال
المتحدث باسم البنتاجون ان روسيا استخدمت
الذخائر العنقوديه بشكل عشوائي منذ بدء
الحرب
وكان مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سالفن قد قال ان كييف ملتزمه بازاله
الذخائر العنقوديه بعد انتهاء الصراع
للتخفيف من اي ضرر على المدنيين واوضح
سالفا ان الولايات المتحده ستوفر الذخائر
العنقوديه لاوكرانيا لان روسيا تستخدمها
بالفعل في عملياتها العسكريه مضيفا ان
واشنطن تشاورت مع حلفائها قبل الموافقه
المانيا كانت قد عبرت عن معارضتها ارسال
ذخائر عنقوديه لاوكرانيا وقال وزير الدفاع
الالماني ان ذلك ليس خيارا لبرنين من
جانبها قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا
لينا باير بوك ان بلادها تعارض ذلك ايضا
بصفتها من بين 111 دوله عضوا في اتفاقيه
حظر استخدام الذخائر العنقوديه
اما الرئيس الاوكراني
فقال ان قوات بلاده لن تستطيع القيام
بهجومها المضاد من دون اسلحه هجوميه
متطوره تتضمن صواريخ بعيده المدى اضاف
زيلينسكي في تصريحات له في العاصمه
التشيكيه براج انه يجب الاسراع في ضم
اوكرانيا الى الاتحاد الاوروبي من جهتها
قال رئيس وزراء تشيك ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
في الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو مضيفا انه
يتوقع ان يدعم شركاء في الحلف انضمام كياف
على حد تعبيره
في هذه الاثناء شدد ديمتري ديف نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي على ضروره العمل على
تعزيز الدفاعات الجويه بما في ذلك داخل
منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
اضافيدف خلال اجتماع لمجموعه العمل
التابعه للجنه للجنه الصناعيه العسكريه
الروسيه ان روسيا بحاجه الى النظر بجديه
لتوريد اسلحه جديده من الغرب الى اوكرانيا
والعمل على انشاء نظام دفعي جوي روسيا
موثوق به واشار الى ان دول الناتو تزيد من
القدرات القتاليه للقوات الاوكرانيه وتزود
كييف بوسائل تدمير حديثه بمدى متزايد
معتبرا ان هذا الوضع خطير للغايه كما قال
المسؤول الروسي انه تجري حاليا دراسه
احتياجات الجيش من الاسلحه مع مراعاه
التهديدات الحاليه
الحديث عن دور المساعدات الامريكيه في دعم
والجدل بشان القنابل العنقوديه سيكون محور
نقاش لنا في فقره في المتابعه بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
قتل الجيش الاسرائيلي اليوم ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه المحتله ففي
قريه ام صفا شماليه رام الله قتلت قوات
الاحتلال شابا فلسطينيا بالرصاص وقالت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الشاب استشهد
جراء اصابته بالرصاص الحي في الصدر وكانت
قريه ام صفا قد شهدت اليوم وجودا مكثفا
لقوات الاحتلال قبل انطلاق مسيره للاهالي
عقب صلاه الجمعه احتجاجا على اقامه بؤره
استيطانيه قرب المدخل الجنوبي للبلده
وفي شرق بلده بيت امور شمال الخليل اصيب
الفلسطيني برصاص مستوطن اسرائيلي خلال
مواجهات مع قوات الاحتلال والمستوطنين كما
اصيب عدد اخر بحالات اختناق جراء
استنشاقهم الغاز السام المسيل للدموع الذي
اطلقه جنود الاحتلال تجاه الشبان ومنازل
المواطنين في البلده
وفي نابلس شيع اهالي الضفه الغربيه جثماني
الشهيدين حمزه مقبول وخيري شاهين الذين
اعدمهما الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامه
البلده القديمه فجر اليوم
المشهد هنا بدايه يتحدث عن نفسه العشرات
من طلقات النار والرصاص الحي اطلقه جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على حمزه مقبول وخير
شاهين اللذان كانا يتحصنان في داخل هذه
الغرفه اشتبكا مع جنود الاحتلال الذين
كانوا يطلقون النار من كافه الاتجاهات الى
داخل المنزل هذه الاغراض الشخصيه للشهيدين
اللذين واضح انهما كانا يتناولان الطعام
ولكن هنا واضح الطلقات الناريه والرصاص
الحي الذي اطلقه الجنود كما ذكرنا من كافه
المواقع وهنا تظهر من النوافذ حجم الرصاص
الذي اطلق وفق شهود العيان الذين كانوا
محاصرين في المنازل القريبه جدا اكدوا انه
بعد نفاذ الذخيره من قبل الشابين حاول
الهروب والخروج من سطح المنزل
شكرا عامر السكسك ولكن بالطبع جنازه
الشهيدين شهدت غضب شديد
المقاومون هنا في نابلس يؤكدون ان ما حدث
في جنين لن يوقف المقاومين الفلسطينيين عن
استمرار المقاومه وفي ظل حاله الغضب التي
تسود كافه انحاء الاراضي الفلسطينيه يتضح
ان الايام القادمه ستشهد المزيد من
التصعيد في ظل كل الاعتداءات والانتهاكات
التي يقوم بها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الجزيره نابلس
ومن نابلس معنا الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
نواف العامر سيدنا نواف ثلاث اعدامات
ميدانيه في يوم واحد كيف قرات الدلالات
والرسائل
اسعد الله اوقاتكم الشهداء الثلاثه اليوم
انضموا الى قافله شهداء فلسطين الذين
اعدمهم الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بدم بارد ليصل
عدد الشهداء الذين قضوا منذ بدايه العام
الحالي 2023 الى
خمسه شهداء مقابل
230 شهيد خلال العام الماضي بمعنى ان نصف
العام لم يكد ينتهي حتى كاد عدد الشهداء
في هذا العام ان يقارب ويوازي شهداء العام
الماضي الرسائل التي اراد الاحتلال ان
يرسلها باعدام الشهداء بدم بارد من خلال
صور التي بثها والمقاطع المتلفزه في
محاوله لاحداث حاله من ردات من
الردع في الشارع الفلسطيني
والتشنيع في عمليه القتل لكي يوقف
الانحدار الامني او انهيار الامني الذي
حصل بالاختراق الذي حققته كتائب القسام في
تل ابي ايام الفائته وامام
مستوطنه قدميم التي احدثت الدربكه في
المقر الذي يسكن فيه وزير الماليه
عمليا ما حصل هو محاوله لترميم الانحدار
الامني الذي حصل ويحاول اعاده روح الثقه
في الامن لان المجتمع الاسرائيلي بعد
العمليات في المستوطنات وفي قلب تل ابيب
يعني او يعني كما تقول بعض التقارير
والروايات المتسربه اثر عدوان مخيم جنين
ان هناك حاله من الاحباط وهناك حاله من
الغضب تمثلت بهجوم الناس على بنجافير
عندما ذهب الى تل ابيب واسمعوه كلمات اخرج
ايها الخائن وهكذا والان يحاولون ان
يرمموا ما حصل بالدم على حساب الدم
الفلسطيني ثم يعلنوه مره اخرى
ترميم ان كانوا يحاولون ترميم هذه الصوره
بماذا ينذر هذا الامر بالنظر الى ما حصل
اليوم
ينذر بالتالي عندما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
مساء امس انه سيؤمن صبيحه الغد ستكون هناك
تعليمات نافذه للجيش الاسرائيلي بان يكون
الجندي على البرج او على الحاجز او في
المركبه التي يقودها على هبه الاستعداد
بحيث تكون الرصاصه في بيت النار وفق
المصطلحات
الخاصه بالسلاح وهذا يعطي مؤشرات على ان
القتل سيكون
مرتفع في صفوف الفلسطين وانهم اعطوا
تعليمات بالقتل على الطائر صيد الشنار كما
يقول المثل الفلسطيني لانهم يريدون ان
يعني يعيدوا بعض الثقه للشارع الاسرائيلي
بعد الخرق الذي حققته كتائب القسام وبعد
الرسائل التي ارسلتها من خلال تبنيها
للعمليات وان القادم كما توعدت الكتائب
سيكون في الحسبان لان الاسرائيلي لا يؤمن
الا بلغه القوه وفق التعليمات او وفق
المعطيات التي رشح منها الكاتب والمحلل
السياسيين وفي العامر ضيفنا من نابلس
في نيويورك عقد مجلس الامن جلسه مشاورات
مغلقه بحث خلالها الاوضاعف الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله بعد العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في مخيم جنين وقدمت لين
هيستنز نائبه منسقه عمليه السلام في الشرق
الاوسط احاطه لاعضاء المجلس بهذا الشان
وكان مندوب فلسطين في المنظمه رياض منصور
التقى هذا الاسبوع الامين العام للامم
المتحده ورئيسه مجلس الامن مندوبه
بريطانيا للمطالبه بتحرك عمليا ملموس
لتوفير حمايه للمدنيين الفلسطينيين
من برمجهام معنى البروفيسور
السياسه والعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
ما الذي يمكن ان يفعله مجلس الامن بالنظر
الى انه يعقد جلسه مغلقه ولا يبدو ان هناك
مقررات ربما قد تخرج عنها
بكل صراحه يمكنني ان اقول لكم الا في حال
قامت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بادانه
الافعال الاسرائيليه هناك القليل الذي
يمكن ان يتم على مستوى مجلس الامن الدولي
وهو ما شاهدناه في مرات متكرره في الصادق
على مستوى مجلس الامن في نزاعات في الضفه
الغربيه وفي قطاع غزه وحتى في خلال الحروب
والهجمات الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت الضفه
وغزه ان مجلس الامن لم يتخذ القرار بارسال
قوات لمراقبه الوضع في الميدان ومجلس
الامن لم يدن هذه الافعال الاسرائيليه حتى
بكلمات تقول ان اسرائيل لم تستخدم القوه
المتناسبه وهذه
الاساسيه على مستوى مجلس الامن الدولي
هناك تسليط للضوء عاده على حجم العنف الذي
نراه تقريبا بشكل يومي
ومحاوله القول بضروره احلال الهدوء ان
الطريقه الوحيده للخروج من هذا
يقولون نريد حمايه من ممارسات الاحتلال
ضدنا ما هي خياراتهم ان كان كما قلت مجلس
الامن لن يتحرك الا اذا اعطت الولايات
المتحده الضوء الاخضر
الخيارات وبالنسبه الى الشعب
الفلسطينيين محدوده للغايه الدفاع عن
الذات هذا هو الخيار الماخوذ من قبل
الفلسطينيين هذه مشكله مستمره عندما ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار حمايه
الفلسطينيين هناك ايضا حديث عن حمايه
الاسرائيليين في داخل تل ابيب والاماكن
الاخرى واستمعت الى الضيف السابق يمكن ان
تستخدم اسرائيل هذه الامور كحجه للمطالبه
بحمايه ايضا وبالتالي حلقت العنف تتوسع
بالنسبه الى الفلسطينيين هناك عدد كبير من
الناس في جنين على مستوى
الشعب الفلسطيني هناك فكره بان السلطه
الفلسطينيه والقوات الرسميه لم تحمي الشعب
الفلسطيني هناك جهود غير منسقه على مستوى
الغربيه وهذه هي مشكله شكرا لك استاذ
السياسه والعلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث عاده المعارك لتشتد بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في محيط المقر
السياديه وتحديدا القياده العامه للجيش
ومقر للاذاعه والتلفزيون في الخرطوم في
الاثناء قال مصدر في الخارجيه السودانيه
للجزيره ان رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح
البرهاني اعتذر عن حضور قمه تجمعه مع قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حماتي دعت
اليها لجنه الايجاد الرباعيه في اديس
ابابا يوم الاثنين المقبل
ما فتيات الحرب بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع تعصف بمناطق عديده في البلاد
وما فتات الوساطات والمبادرات المختلفه
التي طرحت في سبيلائها تتارجح عاجزه عن
تحقيق اي اختراق في الخرطوم اعلن مصدر
دبلوماسي رفيع ان رئيس مجلس السياده
والقائد العام للجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
اعتذر عن حضور لقاء يجمعه بنائبه وحليفه
السابق قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو ضمن قمه دعت لها لجنه رباعيه منبثقه
عن منظمه ايجاد الاقليميه وكان من المفترض
عقد القمه الاثنين المقبل في العاصمه
الاثيوبيه اديس ابابا
طرحت ايجاد عقد هذه القمه ضمن خطه عمل
خاصه بالشروع في عمليه سياسيه جامعه
للتوصل الى تسويه للنزاع بين الطرفين
وقدمت الدعوه للاتحاد الافريقي والولايات
المتحده والمملكه العربيه السعوديه الذين
طرحوا من قبل مبادرات لحل النزاع
يعتبر الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع
قوات متمرده على الشرعيه ويقول ان وقف
الحرب القائمه حاليا يقوم على حل هذه
القوات وتسريح افرادها ويرفض وضع الجيش
معها في موضع النديه ويشدد على ان للسودان
جيشا واحدا كسائر الدول وقد تمردت عليه
هذه القوات التابعه له
في هذه الاثناء تتواصل الحرب في اتجاهات
مختلفه ويقول الجيش انه صده يوما شنته
قوات الدعم السريع على مقر قيادته العامه
في الخرطوم ودمر عددا من الاليات القتاليه
التابعه له كما نفذ قصفا يوميا على محيط
الاذاعه والتلفزيون ومعسكر المظلات التابع
للدعم السريع في شنبات بالخرطوم بحره في
المقابل تقول قياده قوات الدعم السريع
انها تصدت لرتل من قوات الجيش بجنوب
دارفور وكبدته خسائر في الارواح والعتاد
وانها اقتحمت وللمره الثانيه خلال 24 ساعه
مدينه بارع بشمال كردفان واحدثت دمهارا
بعدد من المواقع والمباني الحكوميه
بالطبع لا توجد احصائيات دقيقه لعدد ضحايا
هذه الحرب المندلعه منذ الخامس عشر من
ابريل الماضي لكن يعتقد انها اسقطت مئات
القتلى والجرحى في مختلف الولايات وشردت
نحو ثلاثه ملايين داخل السودان وخارجه
وتهدد بكارثه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه كبرى في
البلاد التي كانت تعاني اصلا صعوبات
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وصراعا سياسيا معقدا
تعتبر الحرب الراهنه من بعض افرازاته
[موسيقى]
بالفعل وهي تريد ان تخرج البرهان يلتقيه
في هذه الدوله او تلك وهذا يطرح سؤال
موضوعي اذا كانت لديهم القدره على اخراج
حميه من الخرطوم لماذا لم تكن لديهم
القدره على ارسال مساعدات انسانيه او طبيه
او علاجيه هذا ابتداء ثانيا معلوم ان هذه
الدول
سيد خالد ما المشكله في اللقاء بحد ذاته
ان كان ربما يفتح بابا للتفاوض لانهاء هذه
الازمه الذي يريد ان يفتح باب للتفاوض يجب
عليه ان يلبي شروط التفاوض ابتداء ابتداء
وتعلمين ان حميدتي وتمرد على الدوله
السودانيه لاحت في السودان يريد لهذه
الحرب ان تستمر ولكن ما هي الشروط التي
توجب ايقاف الحرب في السودان انا فارغه
لديهم
تقاطع مصالح في القضيه هم ليسوا محيدين في
هذه القضيه وهذا الذي عانيت بكيفيه
اخراجهم لحميتي وغض النظر والطرف عن ارسال
المساعدات ولم يدينوا الفزعات التي ارتكبت
في حق الشعب السوداني هذه القضيه لا حياد
فيها المحايد يجب ان يوجه صوت اللوم لمن
يرتكب الخروقات والذي يرتكب الخروقات في
هذه المعركه والدعم السريع الذي يعاني
الشعب السوداني اذا هنا ايضا سؤال هل هذا
الرفض ياتي من منطلق ان السودان يرفض
مبادره الايجاد ويرفض دور الايجاد في هذه
الوساطه اي وساطه محتمله ام انه يرفض
المبدا تماما مبدا اللقاء مع حماتي بكل
تاكيد السودان لا يرفض مبدا ايقاف الحرب
بابتداء وسواء شاهدنا تصريحات للقائد
العام للقوات المسلحه في اكثر من مره انه
يدعو الى قاف الحرب وعدد من المبعوثين حتى
مالك عقار طلب من روسيا وحتى مبعثي وزاره
الخارجيه وبيانات كثيره تدعو الى قاف
الحرب ولكن انا دائما اكرر هذه الجزئيه
شروط ايقاف الحرب هي بيت القصيد في هذه
المعركه لا يمكن ان تعود الاوضاع الى ما
كان عليه الحال قبل 15 ابريل الشعب
السوداني يعاني حتى التدخلات الدوليه
جميعها غير حميده تعلمين ان الاداره
الامريكيه كمثال هي ايضا باطروحات ولكن
يفترض سيد سيدي ان توضع هذه الشروط في
اطار المفاوضات وفي اطار اللقاء هل يجب ان
تكون موجوده بشكل مسبق ومن قال ان السودان
لم يضع الشروط استاذه
ووضع الشروط يوما ذكر القائد العام في
بيان المشهود ان قوات الدعم السريع مرحب
بها ان تدمج ان ارادت الاندماج وان
الخارجين على القانون يجب ان يحاكموا وانه
لا مجال لبقاء هذه القوات خارج مظله
المؤسسه العسكريه الامنيه ممثله في الجيش
الوطني السوداني اذا الشروط موجوده لماذا
لا تخرج قوات الدعم السريع وتلبي شروط هذا
الدمج الذي لباه بالفعل الذي رباه بالفعل
الالاف من ابناء الدعم السريع من ابناء
السودان وليس الغازات الذين عبروا الحدود
هناك عشرات الالوف من السيارات التي سلم
الطواعيه الى قيادات الوحدات وعشرات
الالوف من الجنود الذين سلموا والقياده
العام حتى وضع بنود لدمج هذه القوات فيما
عرف قوات الحدود الحدود اذا ما الذي يمنع
قوات الدعم السريعه ان تصدر بيان هكذا وان
كان بذكاء اصطناعي او خلافه لكي تدمج في
المؤسسه العسكريه نحن لا نريد لهذه الحرب
ان تستمر ولا احد في السودان يغرق في ان
تستمر هذه الحروب ولكن الدعم السريع ظل
يرتكب خروقات واخيرا اليوم في كردفان في
مناطق عزيزه في بارا في دارفور والسودان
جميعه يعاني من هذه المعركه ليس هذه
القريه المدينه او تلك عفوا اذا سمعته
بالنسبه الاداره الامريكيه التي ايضا تقدم
دعوات السؤال الموضوعي في السودان هي اكبر
محطه عسكريه للاداره الامريكيه في افريقيا
هي تراقب هذه المحطه بالستلايت بالقمار
الصناعيه وتحلى تعلم الخروقات التي ارتكبت
في دارفور لماذا لم تسجل صوت لهم لقوات
الدعم السريع بل الام في المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لماذا لم يوجه صريحه لقوات الدعم
السريع باعتبار انها ترتكب خروقات تتصل
بجرائم ضد الانسانيه
السوداني ضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو
وقبل ان نتابع ننوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل
الذي ورد قبل قليل رئيس الوزراء الهولنديه
يقول انه سيقدم استقالته بعد اخفاق
التحالف الحكومي في الوصول الى اتفاق بشان
سياسات الهجره وهذه صور مباشره للمؤتمر
الصحفي لرئيس الوزراء الهولندي الذي يعلن
فيه عن تقديم استقالته
الى تونس حيث يطالب المئات من ضحايا
الانتهاكات في الفتره السياسيه السابقه في
تونس بتنفيذ توصيات هيئه الحقيقه والكرامه
التي اشرفت على مسار العداله الانتقاليه
ورغم مضي ثلاث سنوات على نشر التقرير
النهائي للهيئه فان الجهات حقوقيه تصف
مسار الانتقال الديمقراطي بالمتعثر وتشدد
على ضروره تحقيق العداله ومحاسبه الجونه
كل ما يحيط بحياه بشير الخلفي يذكره بما
تعرض له من انتهاكات مورسات ضد كثير من
التونسيين في العهود السياسيه السابقه
من جديد كم صرت بحب الحياه بشير يقول بصوت
مرتفع ما سكتت عنه اجهزه الدوله بشان
تعذيب سجناء سياسيين حتى بعد ارساء منظومه
العداله الانتقاليه احنا تمسكنا بالعدد
الانتقاليه
وبمقاومه الاستبداد
والنقطه مع الماضي من انتهاكات علاش نقول
لابد من محاسبه
لضمان عدم الافلات من العقاب في المستقبل
هيئه الحقيقه والكرامه التي تاسست عام
2014 كانت العنوان الابرز لملف العداله
الانتقاليه في تونس وقد وجدت جلسات
الاستماع العلنيه التي نظمتها صدا شعبيا
واسعا حيث تم الاستماع الى نحو 55 الف
شهاده لضحايا الاستبداد
[موسيقى]
لكن اليوم وبعد ثلاث سنوات من اختتام
اعمالها ما زالت توصيات التقرير النهائي
للهيئه حبيسه الادراج مجتمع المدني في
تونس
والضحايا وعائلاتهم مسرون على العوده الى
هذا المسار هذاك علاش نعتبره ان الدوله
الحاليه هي الدوله تخرق القانون لما تنكر
مسار العداله الانتقاليه لا وجود لالغاء
قانون العداله الانتقاليه رغم ان الدستور
اللي عملوا قيس سعيد لا ينص على العداله
الانتقاليه ف ان القانون موجود ويجب ان
يطبق وترى الجهات المدنيه والحقوقيه في
تونس ان التقلبات السياسيه التي شهدتها
البلاد خلال الفتره الاخيره ساهمت في
تهميش موضوع العداله الانتقاليه وتعثر
مساره واليوم لا يخفي كثيرون توجسهم من ان
يصبح طيا النسيان في ظل ما تطرحه سلطه من
مقاربات جديده في هذا الاطار
قد يبدو المكان مجرد حطام وركام لمبنى
قديما لكنه بالنسبه لكثيرين من ضحايا
استبداد ما قبل الثوره في تونس خزان
ذكريات يابون نسيانها رغم ما تحمله من الم
وقسوه على هذه الرقعه كان سجن تسعه ابريل
يطبق اسواره على شتى اصناف الانتهاكات
والتعذيب هدم السجن وظلت الذاكره وعصيه
على النسيان ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره تونس
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى القرار الامريكي بتزويد
اوكرانيا بقنابل عنقوديه قدمت الولايات
المتحده في مختلف جولات الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا اسلحه نوعيه ساعدت في معاركها
وفي تغيير مسار الحرب احيانا ابرز هذه
الاسلحه منظومه هاي مارس بعيده المدى
وعاليه الدقه بالاضافه الى صواريخ ستينجر
وجافلن ودبابات ابرمز كما قدمت واشنطن
لكييف انظمه دفاع جوي متطوره منها
الامريكيه واليوم يجري الحديث عن القنابل
العنقوديه التي صممت لضرب الدبابات
والعربات المدرعه وتدميرها او تعطيلها على
الاقل ويمكن ان تغطي كل قنبله مساحه تصل
الى 30 الف متر مربع حسب الارتفاع الذي
تطلق منه القنابل الصغيره لكن هذه القدره
تواجه اشكالا مهما يتعلق بمعد فشل مرتفعه
نسبه الخطا فيها تبلغ 6% وهي نسبه تضع
تصديرها واستخدامها امام عقبات قانونيه
نسبه الخطا هذه اوجدت خلافا كبيرا بشان
وضع هذه القنابل ضمن قائمه المساعدات
عموما هناك 120 دوله وقعت على اتفاقيه
خاصه تحضر استخدام وتخزين وانتاج الذخائر
العنقوديه تقول منظمات دوليه ان كلا من
روسيا واوكرانيا استخدمت هذه الذخائر خلال
الحرب ذخائر لا ينفجر بعضها مما يشكل خطرا
ولو بعد سنوات ولذلك نرى شرطا امريكيا وضع
اليوم على كييف يلزمها بتحديدا دقيق
لاماكن استخدامها لمتابعتها في المستقبل
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من جنيف
الدكتور الكسوندر فوترافير رئيس تحرير
المجله العسكريه السويسريه دكتور اليكسوند
ما دلالات اقدام الولايات المتحده على هذه
الخطوه
هناك عدد من الاسباب اولا هناك
الذخائر التي يمكن ان تستخدم
القصف قصف المدفعيه وهي تضر او اكثر
فعاليه باربع مرات من الذخائر التقليديه
المستخدمه هذا هو السبب الاول وسبب الثاني
هو ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وعدد اخر من البلدان الذي يهم مخزون كبير
جدا من هذه الذخائر وهي بالتالي متاحه على
الفور لاوكرانيا ولكن
ايضا المضاد
لكل تاكيدا ان الهجوم المضاد وسلسله
العمليات الاوكرانيه المستمره من الجانب
الاوكراني ادت الى الرد فعلا قوي من
القوات المسلحه الروسيه وعلى وجه الخصوص
شهدت المنطقه هجمات مضاده من جانب الروس
وذلك من خلال استخدام الذخائر التقليديه
وهنا تبرز او يبرز الحديث عن هذه الذخائر
العنقوديه التي يمكن ان يستفيد منها الجيش
الاوكراني لاستهدافي المدرعات بالمقارنه
مع ذخائر التقليديه غير الفعاله كثيرا في
هذه المجالات
تبرير الذي
مقال انه يجري اعطاء اوكرانيا هذه الذخائر
العنقوديه لان ذخيره اوكرانيا حاليا اخذ
في النفاذ
هذا صحيح وفي الوقت نفسه راينا
التحديات او راينا بالفعل القنوات
اللوجستيه القنوات اللوجستيه التي بنيت
لاشهر تحضيرا لهذه العمليه المضاده هناك
قنوات لوجستيه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عبر اوروبا وصولا الى اوكرانيا
وهذه القنوات اللوجستيه قويه للغايه وعدد
كبير من البلدان يشتري ذخائر جديده من اجل
الوفاء بالتزاماته تجاهه اوكرانيا وتزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخيره وبالتالي انا لا اعتقد
ان ذخيره سوف تنفذ في اوكرانيا لربما بعض
الانواع المحدده طبعا من الذخائر يصعب ان
تصل في القريب العاجل الى اوكرانيا هي
تتطلب وقتا اطول وهذا يعود بنا الى ضروره
تزويد اوكرانيا بالذخيره التي هي بحاجه
اليها في هذه العمليه المضاده
ستستخدم هذه الذخائر العنقوديه
ووفق المعلومات الغربيه روسيا ايضا تستخدم
هذه الذخائر العنقوديه ما المشهد الذي
يمكن ان نتوقعه ميدانيا
ميدانيا روسيا كما تفضلتي استخدمت وتستخدم
هذه الذخائر العنقوديه
وايضا استخدمت الاسلحه الحراريه في الوقت
نفسه
واستخدمت اسلحه غير قانونيه لان هذه
الاسلحه تؤدي الى حرق
البناء والاشخاص داخل المباني كما تعرفون
ميدانيا معظم سكان تلك المناطق تم اجلائهم
يتحدثوا عن المناطق الحدوديه وبالتالي
التاثير المباشر على سكان المنطقه سوف
يكون محدودا على الارجح ولكن يجب ان ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار حقيقه ان بعض هذه الذخائر
قد تستخدم بطريقه اخرى
بتحديد دقيق للاماكن التي يتم فيها
استخدام هذه القنابل حتى لا تشكل قنابل
موقوته في المستقبل خصوصا انها يمكن ان
تنفجر بعد سنوات هل هذا الشرط واقعي هل
يمكن فعليا حصر الضرر الكبير الذي تشكل
هذه الذخائر على الناس
هو واقعي وبالاضافه الى ما تفضلت به اليوم
هناك اداره عبر اجهزه الكمبيوتر اداره
اوتوماتيكيه من خلال من خلالها يمكن منع
استخدام الذخيره في مناطق محدده
وبالتالي هناك محدوديه لاستخدام هذه
الذخيره في المناطق الحضاريه طبعا يجب الى
هذه النقطه الاهتمام الضروري هناك عدد
كبير من الجيوش الذي يستخدم هذه الذخائر
على نقديه ولهذه الذخائر قواعد صارمه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر السيد الكسندر
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
ضيفنا من جنيف
بهذا مشاهدينا نصل الى نهايه نهايه حصاد
هذه الليله شكرا لمتابعتكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]